[Music]
[Applause]
I'll take that yeah the
ASAP okay you're double backed I'm
double
backed rising to over 9,000 ft these
mountains have a different climate to
the aid deserts below during the monsoon
season rainstorms can lead to flash
floods creating a significant impact on
anyone living
here and coli tells me on the mountains
the
elv to understand these mountains you
have to go down there you have to go
inside okay so who's going first you're
going first no no no you go you don't
trust
me okay I'm going first you safy
y CL
in don't unlocked the harness is good
yeah double backed I'm ready let's do it
let's do
it walking the same
line oh my
[Music]
God give me a little
slack happy to be the first no
[Music]
enjoy The
[Applause]
Descent oh
[Music]
man
wow this Cavern is over 300 ft deep and
hundreds of feet
wide wow look at
this it's like an underground
[Music]
Cathedral
oh
[Music]
man Albert are you
down I made
it I'm going to get out of the way and
then make your way
down look at this
place
yeeha
[Music]
C there a little
speck
wow you never would have imagined
standing on the top that this was down
here what a place
heyy I've been in many caves but nothing
like
this it's not only desert here this is
all the work of the water what yes
this is limestone of course and uh it
was practically carved by water you know
raining water I mean this takes a lot of
water to make something this big eating
away over time oh yes
yes there are so many others it's like
swiss cheese you have holes everywhere
some of them are broken and empty and
the other ones are still
full wow that's
[Music]
amazing